francis hogan the facebook whistleblower
leaked the internal instagram research
into teenagers and well-being her claim
is that instagram is choosing profit
over well-being of teenage girls so
instagram is quote toxic for them
your response titled what our
research really says about teen
well-being and instagram says no
instagram research shows that 11 of 12
well-being issues
teenage girls
who uh said they struggle with those
difficult issues also said that
instagram made them better rather than
worse
again can you steal man and defend the
point
and uh francis hogan's characterization
of the study and then helped me
understand the positive and negative
effects of instagram or facebook on
young people
so
there are certainly questions around
teen mental health that are really
important it's hard to you know as a
parent it's like hard to imagine any set
of questions that are sort of more
important i guess maybe other aspects of
physical health or or well-being um or
probably come to that level but like
these are really important questions
right which is
why we dedicate teams to studying them
um
you know i don't think the internet or
social media um are unique in having
these questions i mean i think people
and there have been sort of magazines
with promoting certain body types for
women and kids for decades but um
you know we really care about this stuff
so we wanted to study it and and of
course you know we didn't expect that
everything was going to be positive all
the time so i mean the reason why you
study this stuff is to try to improve
and get better so i mean look the place
where i disagree with the
characterization first
i thought you know some of the reporting
and coverage of it just took the whole
thing out of proportion and that it
focused on as you said i think there
were like 20 metrics in there and on you
know 18 or 19 the effect of using
instagram was neutral or positive on the
on the teens well-being and there was
one area where where i think um it
showed that we needed to improve and we
took some steps to try to do that um
after doing the research but but i think
having the coverage just focus on that
one without focusing on the you know i
mean i think an accurate
characterization would have been that
kids using instagram or not kids teens
um
is is generally positive for their
mental health um but of course that was
not the narrative that came out so i
think it's hard to that's not a kind of
logical thing to straw man but i sort of
disagr or steal man but i sort of
disagree with that overall
characterization i think anyone sort of
looking at this
um
objectively would
um but then you know i mean the the
there is this sort of intent
critique that i think you were getting
at before which which says it would
assume some sort of malevolence right
it's like um
which it's it's really hard for me to
really wrap my head around this because
as far as i know
it's not clear that any of the other
tech companies are doing this kind of
research so
why the narrative should form that we
did research because we were studying an
issue because we wanted to understand it
to improve and took steps after that to
try to improve it that your
interpretation of that would be that
that we did the research and tried to
sweep it under the rug it just it sort
of um
is like
i don't know it's beyond credibility to
me that like that's the accurate
description of the actions that we've
taken compared to the others in the
industry so i don't know that that's
that's kind of that's that's my view on
it um these are really important issues
and there's a lot of stuff that i think
we're going to be working on related to
teen mental health for a long time
including trying to understand this
better
and i would encourage everyone else in
the industry to do this too
yeah i
would love there to be open
conversations and a lot of great
research being released internally and
then also
externally it um it doesn't make me feel
good
to see press obviously get way more
clicks when um
they say negative things about social
media
objectively speaking i can just tell
that there's hunger to say negative
things about social media
and um
i don't understand how that's supposed
to lead to an open conversation about
the positives and the negatives the
concerns about social media especially
when you're doing those that kind of
research
you